I was like you know the meal preps
working out in the morning joging like
running like crazy this looks like the
get lean
program yeah you're you're freaking your
journey was crazy yeah show them your
abs dude I don't have any show them your
abs right now lift it up time's up time
lift it
[Music]
up all right welcome back everybody to
an amazing episode of the careful boys
where today we are sitting here with the
man himself Mr Michael Lee AKA just
Michael raise your hand if you have no
idea who he is we follow each other on
Instagram I have something to say why do
you have what what do you have against
him being hydrated yeah What's your deal
dude cuz it's not it's not careful boys
or barbell merch what actually I just
bought the barbell uh Vietnamese coffee
you did oh thank you so much that's not
that's truth baby's truth you could
drink as much water as you want yeah
yeah D drink as much water like I say
okay so better questions
Bart does it taste good I haven't tried
it I just got it water yeah gave me a
it's my favorite protein we've dropped
in our history your guys's ads are my
favorite agree can I say something I
bought um I bought Optimum Nutrition uh
a protein brand against they got cool
ads that are racist yeah they're not but
I bought I bought a a mocha cappuccino
flavor you you know why I bought it
actually too when you posted you had the
caption in Asian in an Asian accent and
maybe and maybe want to buy it more oh
has nothing to do with protein or
nutrition facts or it worked I was like
that looks cool it l it looked funny
yeah it worked that's that's what's kind
of hilarious we've speaking of first
week of October careful Bo let's go baby
let's
go dang that was smooth no that's that
was something that we notice that's
really weird like we if we actually talk
about the main points of the product
like how good they nobody cares no one
gives a [__] don't tell me the health
benefits yeah we just do something fun
and people love it you think it comes
across like salesy if you do it that way
instead of making fun of whatever the
which by the way is another opportunity
reminds you that we have merchandise but
for me like say I'm buying a car right I
want to know oh cool like this motor
this I like knowing specs I don't want
to be like the car commercials like how
much [__] you're going to get in this
car I think for most people they go this
is the kind of [__] you're going to get
and you're like oh I'm going just let me
get that car right away it's subliminal
dud so I thought I thought protein would
be like that if you're like okay cool
this is zero fat zero carb you know and
then people oh I want that but it's not
they don't give a [__] they go oh what
the hell this guy's doing a ching chong
commercial [__]
yeah it's like it's Loki the standard
already cuz a lot a lot of people
already are like yeah I worked really
hard in this product so like it's kind
of it's a lot about marketing I have
never seen that flavor though for that
product I've never seen that and fact
that was Vietnamese coffee and I'm
vietamese so I was like oh oh and it's
very it's just just so good it's really
good that is huge too though because
like 99% of like all protein that you
find in the store is like chocolate
vanilla maybe strawberry or strawana and
guess what they all tastes like [__]
they hon do they honestly do but this
one actually tastes like except for fair
life shout outs to Fair life their
stuff's really good I don't know how
they do it not sponsored but go support
them I like
how have you had Quest conflicting show
Quest what nutrition like all their
whole I have and what are you about to
say yeah they're all their products are
really good they sent me a care package
the they're so
good what were you about to say what
were you about to say shakes the protein
sh yeah there's a caramel flavor and it
tastes like a it tastes like a a
Starbucks like he's going to clip this
later for his ad yeah what were you
about to say though yeah can I be real
why don't you pigy back off that I think
in 2014 or
2015 I was sponsored tastes like [__]
but I just still just drink it cuz I was
sponsored and I'm Asian so if you get it
for free it's like you have to just tast
got uh but their Quest chips is the
first thing that made me fall back in
love with their new stuff and I have
never tried any of their new new because
I'm scared of how nasty used to taste I
I I so I I got their chips right and I I
like post on my story I was like Hey
like I love your stuff they I asked them
for a care package so they sent me
everything else too wow so I was like
low key I'm not going to lie I was like
damn like I don't want to waste it cuz I
felt the same way cuz it tastes like
[__] everything tastes so good it it it
mimics every single chip brand like from
LS to uh freaking Takis yeah yeah yeah
yeah like literally everything I like
the pink one the green one and the blue
one green one's my favorite it's funny
how it went from a barbell ad to now a
quest ad
but that's how it goes here dude but
we're trying to get to know Michael oh
yeah we know he likes Quest dude know
that so is he a fitness influencer are
we trying to guess no I I I'm getting
back into yeah you guys should
definitely try to guess I I I I okay
stino's Anthony you dance good deduction
right there that's a pretty good all
right all right he does do that he does
do that getting warm actually that's
pretty much on the button this exactly
what I actually don't think that there's
other way describe what's the difference
between dancing and making Tik Tok
videos no they're just two separate
things but fused together he's dancing
on a Tik Tok and instead of dancing on
Yahoo but I'm not like a I'm not a Tik
Tok dancer
though it's like a difference you know
he went viral through email dude what
what was that no there's there's like
cuz you know when you hear like Tik Tok
dancer it's not like real dancing so I
like I come from like the background of
like an actual dancer like oh some of
the dancers I see on Tik Tok are crazy
well now they are now yeah yeah before
they weren't like all the twerking
that's crazy d That's great dance so so
you twerk on Tik Tok yeah yeah okay got
you when you say you came from like like
traditionally trained like what's your
dance background like I started I
started dancing in 2012 at a studio and
like jazz no hip-hop okay all
specifically hipop question and then
2015 I like quote unquote be became like
professional is started doing like music
videos and like the laddin
and then I started social media doing
dancing and then fast forward to 2019
that's when Tik Tok came out and I was
like the first PE person to like be on
it type of thing and the first week I
hopped on I gained like a million
followers in a week holy [__] the first
week and then after that can you teach
us a class yeah and every week after
that I kept gaining a million and then
by like a million a week holy [__] you
know how long it took us to hit 2
million I never heard anybody brag like
that yeah I know it was it was Wild by
the time by the time I moved out it was
like May 2020 I had like 25 million on
your Tik Tok What do you have Now 52 God
damn does it ever go down that's a small
country bro I know it's it's wild no
you're more than South Korea it honestly
doesn't like Russia I would say
followers on Tik Tok doesn't even matter
as much though anymore why cuz it's all
Chinese no cuz the video doesn't go
viral it won't go viral like you'll have
like a base set of views I see what's
your B set what's like your Baseline if
it's like a bad video yeah what's a bad
video like 2 to 400,000 views what the
[__] like it's a good video it'll be
like but that's a huge disparity though
if you got 50 million views I mean uh
subscribe followers and then you got
400,000 that's a huge but that also
means every video he posts all of
Bakersfield watches it oh yeah every
single video Bakers Fresno
Modesto the whole y dude Yuka dude all
of yuka's dang Prett can I a maybe
racist question depending if you're
racist or not yeah all right are you
racist if you're if you're really good
at hip-hop right uhhuh and like let's
say You outd dance a black guy yeah do
you was think can you take their black
card away oh and you're like I'm more
black than you I felt like I I I it
wasn't more of like if I'm better than
them but like if I danced around them a
lot in a circle no no more of like in
Florida I used to have only like as or
no no Asians there was no Asians really
in Florida around me it was all Black
and Hispanic people so I felt like I was
like part of them that's why like if you
go back I kind of like looked more
Hispanic and I talked more like ghetto
kind of I don't know like I just had
like more of like an accent like kind of
like just how it was yeah and then um
you know I felt like I was a part of it
you know but no I wouldn't say would to
say I'm racist you don't think of black
then would to say I'm
racist they don't they don't you don't
take their card if anything they like uh
give you like a hall pass of acceptance
for that moment to say what word they
give you a h pass to say what word
anony this is the clip that get
C say what set this
up he wants the Eminem Hall Pass when I
could when I mean a black dude that
could speak better Chinese in me I'm
like you call me what the [__] you
want you get extra points you see those
uh the black arban singers in the Farms
yep they've been singing away dude the
agriculturalist singers it looks no
there's like it's I feel like they're
African Farmers that learn Chinese
really well and then it it's almost like
they Farm by day and at night they sing
Chinese
karaoke and it's like perfect it's
perfect you don't know what I'm talking
about I've never seen those dudes it is
pretty crazy to see like a non-asian
person speaking Mandarin like perfectly
you just go like I'm for me I don't
speak so I like go I've been man my
Japanese car has been taken so many
times I'll be in Japan [__] and like I
see a black guy and I'll be like oh [__]
what's up dude and then they can't even
speak English and [__] and then they
just speak perfect Japanese and I'm like
oh man you're I thought you're La man
they're they're ripping your Japanese
car in front yeah dude it's ripped up
you can't get it back I'm the one with
wrong Japanese on my body and
it's technically a different kind of
right is it you know the first character
actually I think in Chinese it says like
[__] uh dinosaur or some [__] really
yeah dinosaur which one yeah the very
first the top character top one says
dinosaur in Chinese it's like the
beginning of dinosaur in Chinese wait so
it's not proper like you n it's wrong
there's nothing proper it's proper dude
don't be spreading false lies it's
proper dude it's [__] hardcore I am
kind of nervous that a Japanese person's
going to look at my shin and then look
at me with disg and that makes they're
going to laugh at you yeah and I'm like
I don't know if I'm ready for that yet
do you think it's going to throw off a
Japanese Jiu-Jitsu like oh it might be a
good technique you could compete in
Japan only compete in Japan it be like
what is that and then you're like
surprise [__] you're sitting real nice
dude have you guys seen Steve's lately
his mosquito by air is [__] up oh
really yeah it's like the Ink's not even
there so he's just got like blot no oh
my he's got to get retouched it's
[__] funny dnor dude so what made you
jump on social media with your dance and
stuff um o it was actually it was like
all the you guys were like one of the
first YouTubers I watched too it was
like you guys Ryan Higa Kev Jumba uh
smos it was like the the ogs I felt like
y oh so you watched back in the
20109 and you still didn't know what we
did what do you mean I do I'm just
kidding no he said he just doesn't watch
this show no I just I don't watch
podcast I only watch anime I'm not going
to lie you you're talking about the old
school just King film stuff I'm talking
about like Uncle chin yeah yeah that's
OG that's tight than you it was cool
Timothy there go yeah so I felt like I I
started social media cuz like y'all were
like having a lot of fun and it was like
basically a career like I basically saw
it and as a dancer there's only like so
much you can do like there's a certain
like level you know like a ceiling of
like is this going to make me money type
of thing cuz I I was always very
business-minded so I was like okay what
if I put dance and like social media and
I kind of do that and I I personally
like that cuz like even if I didn't make
enough money at the time I still loved
it so like I did that compared to like
working at 95 so yeah that's why I
started did you have the common Asian
struggle where your parents were like
what the [__] are you doing yeah yeah my
whole family everyone was like just like
you should go to college I dropped out
of high school be a pharmacist you
dropped out of high school that's even
crazy I dropped out uh after sophomore
year wao that's do you even know your
continents
then doesn't matter
see doesn't matter no I I was I was I
was like the typical Asian where like I
was like dual enrollment straight A I
was doing college classes already so
like by the time I was sophomore and
sophomore oh you could drop out bro I
was doing pre-cal already oh you're
smarter than the average American at
sophomore after that had like that like
senioritis my dad had like a screen
printing embroidery business and he was
like oh help me and I was like oh yeah
please so I quit school I did that and
then I that was Dad convinc you to quit
school yeah that's and then so your dad
child labored you yes F tight Asian I
started off I did like it was supposed
to be like 9 and5 but I ended up being
the only worker there the 9 and9 so like
yeah like a 9 to 12 type thing it's like
I replaced my 9 to5 for a 5 to n let's
go yeah so it that that was like a thing
that made me like okay I never want to
do a 9 and5 again and then social media
started popping off or at least d
dancing like being a choreographer and
stuff and then yeah 2019 happened and
now I'm here what did your uh family say
when they just see you like cuz you know
like when you do your own thing you're
just in your own lane and you're in your
own world when did it first go back
around and reach your family where they
discovered your stuff through their own
like feed when you like bought them all
mansions and [__] that's pretty cool um
like where they like started supporting
where they're just like what the [__] I
know that guy uh I would say more
i' say more of when 2019 I mean when
2019 happened like my whole life like
flipped cuz I was live with my parents
and then I moved out like a couple
months afterwards and then I moved my
mom and siblings out here so like my
whole like income like you got money
like that 100x and 100x yeah I mean I
was like literally dirt I didn't have
anything and then I I bought a house or
I didn't buy a house but like I I
prepaid like a house during coid a year
up front because like I was so young I
couldn't like just like be like oh yeah
how much money did you make in 2020 you
think 20 like probably 3 to 4 mil
damn good
job and this is purely through Tik Tok
yeah like sponsorships like I was
getting like sponsorships of like 50 to
100 150 like per brand deal yeah like
promote these [__] new Quest chips
like you secretly just
did he Grand right now he's working on
his next sponsor no but it was crazy cuz
like Tik toks are like 15 30 seconds so
I was like you could crank them out like
crazy yeah and that's all I was doing
did you have an agent breaking the deals
for you or did you do all the
negotiations yeah I had different agents
and stuff and then I found like a person
that stuck with so yeah when you first
got your check like were you like what
the [__] what was the first crazy that's
a salary of a person's whole year in 30
seconds I remember the first day of like
living in La cuz I got like this it was
a it was a three story it was like a a b
basement a giant basement with like a
theater a whole like gym indoor pool
outdoor pool it was everything so like
the first day I moved in I woke up that
morning and I like I was like is this
real like am I is it really happening so
it was crazy oh cuz you moved in from
like your like the house you grew up in
what was the most irresponsible purchase
that you made [__] the nft the nft
[__] what you buy everything did you
buy an egg [__] everything I spent
like I I probably lost like 2 mil I'm
not going to lie I spent a lot do you
feel bad anymore Anthony I mean it's all
relative if he's making 3 to 4 mil and
losing 2 that's different from if you're
making [__] feel like
I I got all of my bad [__] out of me
though from that and like I kind of
learned from there but no that was it
was like it was just like money
management I wouldn't say nfts itself
was bad cuz like I I was able to like
figure [__] out but like it was it was a
bad GJ moves yeah that was really really
bad you still make the same or more or
less um now I I would say I make a
little bit less but it's also cuz I'm
like rebranding I'm trying to refocus
cuz like I feel like I even though I
blew up I like started focusing on [__]
I didn't want to focus on which was like
you know what works versus what you want
to do I was fully in like [__] let's
do what works like play the algorithm
yeah and then I lost I lost like my uh
who Am I who was what an example of what
worked and and what something that you
wanted to do twerking twerk yeah I was
twerking on camera I actually was I
throw in the back yeah okay so twerking
definitely worked it was a little cringy
that's what he wanted to do that's not
what just works oh yeah yeah clarify
here no it was um yeah I feel like I
stopped I F I stopped dancing for a
little bit too like for like a solid two
years Dam and then now I'm like what
kind of Legacy do I even have so like
now I'm like really rebranding and
really trying to focus on to like how
like can I like change the dance world
he was even in that uh group that did
the Tik tokers versus YouTube YouTuber
boxing
match that in a Creator's boxing thing
so okay remember who did you go up
against I went uh against FaZe FaZe
Jarvis okay okay so I had it was crazy
so Austin came into my house like two
three like 3 months before he offered
like the deal was supposed to be for
400k okay I had one month to train what
did one month of training my whole like
fitness journey completely like 180d and
that was like the first time I ever got
super it and then how much were you
training a day um I was training pretty
much every I was training every day for
for the month but the thing was like we
had like technically two to 3 months but
they didn't give me any trainer or
anyone so I had to look and I couldn't
find anyone good until that last month
oh [__] so I was just training on my
fitness for that for that meantime this
guy man you should have this guy train
if you want to get knocked out bro you
can hire me man I'm really good at I'm
really good at getting knocked out thing
is like I'm very proud of like how far
wen't you scared that's awesome weren't
you scared or you just like scary bro it
was nerve-wracking no no was it your
first fight yeah I never fought like
ever are you going to do it again you
think you would um if I trained in it
yeah I think I would it was just it was
a lot of that that actually made me
Rebrand because I realized from that
fight um it was a lot of hate during it
and afterwards cuz I lost and why do
people hate yeah what because people are
just like they their kids every it's
like high school like on steroids so
everyone like every video I posted for
like the next eight months like but you
lost though or yeah it's like oh still
you are you woking up are you like you
still sleeping like those type of [__]
it was so aggravating but like you
trained for only a month that made me
like realize I was like this is like
this is the brand I have like I don't
have like a loyal kind of thing and
that's why like it's too like fast food
yeah yeah exactly that's why I was like
I need to like switch this up I need to
focus on something I actually love and
then I can actually have have like an
audience or like fan base that actually
like you know [__] with me type of
thing good thing you're here we're the
Cockroaches of YouTube we just survive
bro no no this is this is really cool
like I'm I'm like still nervous right
now cuz I'm like holy [__] still I've
watched you you're about to show us
something that you're proud of yes well
you're going to show us that you punch
somebody no no no no my uh he's going to
show us his
hands it's your body transformation yeah
you were probably [__] fat no were
you fat or skinny I was I was pretty
[__] chubby were you yeah cuz I
didn't really work out did you make it
as a chubby dancer yeah I was doing
pretty good I wasn't chubby I was just
like skinny fat I like that one fat guy
that dances really well in China I know
one in Korea that danc like that he
always wearing goggles I like that wait
is he the the one that dances in the
rain talking the guy that does Ray J's
one wish and he like get his clothes
thrown at him that clip is [__] money
that was good
they better hurry up dude running out of
time bro this is my this was my journey
damn I like how you put the dates right
over your dick so you can't just in
case
wow CA Fitness guys holy [__] got this
is a one month transformation that was
probably like 3ish months but it was
like hard bro you're [__] Jack dude I
I'm different now but this was like I'm
different now I'm getting back to that
I'm getting back to turn it to Bruce man
yeah I felt I felt really good damn good
job hell yeah good job I was like you
know the meal preps working out in the
morning joging like running like crazy
this looks like the get lean
program yeah you're you're freaking your
journey was crazy yeah show them your
abs dude I don't have any AB show them
your abs right now lift it up time's up
time Up Lift It
Up
he